what are some common mistakes that
writers make in the first two stages of
writing and the screenplay which
compromises the first act and then
subsequent acts what are usually the
first parts that end up compromising the
entire work yeah I would I would go
actually a little further with your
question I would say if you have
problems in the first two stages you're
it's impossible for your script to work
I have this sort of motto and that is if
you're having story problems all roads
lead to the hero's outer motivation
because one of the biggest issues one of
the most difficult things for writers to
really embrace is there is this idea
that at the very foundation of any story
is a visible goal that the hero wants to
cross at the end of the story they'll
get so caught up in the inner journey in
the depth or dimension of the character
or in the themes they want to deliver or
they'll just think the premise is good
so they get lost in a thicket of events
and plotting until finally they're just
coming up with new ideas and adding idea
after idea and it becomes so complicated
and so confusing that there's no story
there if you think about it most
Hollywood movies in particular are based
on very simple story ideas you may need
to take a story that you think is fairly
complex like Inception okay that seems
pretty complicated I had a little
trouble grasping some of that but it's
very core it's very simple a group of
people wants to penetrate a person's
dreams down to a layer where they can
change his behavior without him knowing
it that's it I was able to say that in
what five seconds and one sentence and
that everything is built on that goal
and if you have that kind of clear
through line and if when you say what
that goal is everybody gets the same
image of what achieving that goal is
then you've laid a foundation that most
scripts don't honestly have and it's
it's all because it sounds simple it is
simple but it's not easy because I think
for those of us who writer for
storytellers we still want to get into
character we still want to get into
deeper levels of meaning we still want
it to be original and different and
complex and special that we lose sight
of first I've got to have this very
simple through line so that's the number
one thing the one of the biggest problem
in stages one and two is it doesn't lead
to a clear visible finish line that
anyone can envision whether they're
reading the script or or watching the
movie they know what they're rooting for
second thing is not showing the everyday
of life of the character before they get
into the story moving forward we have to
have a set up it can be very brief or a
character can be on the move so to speak
action wise they can have just arrived
in a town and we see them going or
they're going to a meeting or going to
meet with a hit man or whatever it might
be but nonetheless it has to convey this
is who this character has been for some
time and it has to create empathy like
Rambo he arrives yeah yeah exactly Brian
so we'll find out what happened prior to
that but the big the first big event
that's going to happen to him doesn't
happen on page one we first have to get
acquainted and identify or empathize
with this character and that empathy
must occur immediately we have to
empathize before we start seeing what
the flaws to the character are before we
start recognizing what this inner
conflict is or what this identity is or
what dark places they might go first we
have to just connect with them
emotionally and the third thing I would
say is jumping from the set up right to
the outer motivation in other words I
think because screenwriters are
inundated with the idea that you got to
grab the reader right away and you've
got to get things going and all your
movies move fast and so on all of that
is true but it doesn't mean you rush the
story what it means is you start
building in conflict as soon as you can
but you don't rush the story it's going
to take all of act 1 to get your hair to
the
where they really begin pursuing that
visible finish line and if you start at
page 10 with them pursuing the goal your
your script is going to die around page
70 because you can't sustain a single
goal that long so you've got to take the
whole stage one in stage two just to
build up to create the opportunity in
the new situation to get them oriented
to build up to the point where they have
the goal and then they take that first
step and that's what has to happen at
25%
you